surveillez la biodiversité en temps réel
comme on le fait avec la météo c'est le
rêve d'une biologie ce canadienne qui
développe un outil inusité basé sur une
idée toute simple un aspirateur
[Musique]
dans un zoo c'est assez facile
d'identifier les animaux ils sont
proches ils bougent presque pas et il y
a des affiches partout avec le nom des
espèces mais Elizabeth Clerc elle peut
les identifier les yeux fermés son
secret c'est d'analyser l'air parce que
dans l'air il y a des traces de tout ce
qui vit autour des indices génétiques
des fragments de leur ADN
autour de nous il y a des animaux des
plantes des champignons il y a plein de
choses qui flottent dans l'air quand je
marche avec mes enfants ou avec mon
chien je me dis qu'en prenant une grande
respiration j'échantillonne en fait
l'ADN qui est dans l'environnement
au zou Toronto est la simulé pour nous
l'expérience qui en a fait une super
star de la biologie
[Musique]
identifier les animaux présents grâce à
l'ADN qui flotte dans l'air une idée un
peu farfelue qu'elle a eu presque par
hasard elle avait déjà étudié le sang
consommé par les sangsues ou la petite
boule que les bousiers transportent
parce que les deux contiennent de l'ADN
des animaux qui vivent autour même
principe avec les ruches d'abeilles
l'ADN permet de dire quelle fleur ont
été visitées c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'ADN environnemental une façon
indirecte de mesurer la biodiversité et
c'est quand on lui a commandé un rapport
sur l'ADN environnemental qu'elle a eu
l'inspiration
les différentes sources d'ADN
environnementales j'ai parlé du sol de
l'ADN qu'on trouve sur les feuilles des
arbres puis j'ai ajouté et dans l'air
j'ai ensuite cherché des études pour
montrer que ça fonctionne et j'ai été
surprise comme experte de voir que
personne ne l'avait essayé avec l'air
après quelques tests en laboratoire
Elizabeth Claire se tourne vers un zoo
en Angleterre où elle habite pour capter
de l'ADN dans l'air
c'est une collection d'espèces qui ne
sont pas dans leur environnement naturel
si je détecte de l'ADN de tigre en
Angleterre c'est nécessairement celui
qui est devant moi il n'y a aucune autre
source possible
c'est l'endroit parfait on sait quels
animaux sont présents et où mais on est
exposé au même conditions météo que dans
l'environnement
et les résultats sont prometteurs
[Musique]
de 1 elle a détecté l'ADN des différents
animaux du zoo dans les échantillons
d'air récoltés à côté de leurs enclos
respectifs mais surtout il y en avait
dans les échantillons pris à 100 200 et
même 300 mètres
s'implique que l'ADN reste longtemps
dans l'air qu'il flotte et qu'il voyage
et c'est exactement ce qu'elle espérait
son équipe a aussi détecté la présence
d'animaux qui officiellement n'habitent
pas au zoo encore mieux même l'ADN des
animaux servent de nourriture aux
résidents du Zou comme le bœuf ou le
poulet finit par se retrouver dans l'air
mais juste avant de publier ces
résultats elle a appris qu'une deuxième
équipe avait fait exactement la même
chose dans un autre zoo d'habitude ça
devient une course ou la première équipe
a publié ses résultats récolte tous les
honneurs
et les abeilles
à l'autre chercheuse de synchroniser
leurs articles
dans ton travail sur un sujet qui évolue
vite il y a un risque de se faire
éclipser par quelqu'un d'autre ça nous
est tous arrivé et ce n'est pas agréable
on se sent mal pour l'autre qui a
investit du temps dans un projet qui ne
sera pas publié ou alors parce que c'est
notre propre travail qui passe inaperçu
dans ce cas-ci les deux équipes sont
très heureuses du résultat et on pense
avoir eu plus d'impact sur la science et
auprès du grand public justement parce
qu'on était deux et ces deux fois plus
tôt qu'une la preuve que c'est un outil
qui est mûr pour aller sur le terrain
cette fois-ci pour étudier les
chauves-souris l'autre spécialité
d'Elizabeth claire et on lui avait
demandé de garder une petite place dans
ses valises pour une caméra question de
devenir nos yeux et nos oreilles en
Amérique centrale
même si les journées commencent à 9
heures on est assez loin du 9 à 5 au
bureau
[Musique]
la première étape c'est de trouver les
chauves-souris
le choix évident ce sont les grottes
[Musique]
avec son étudiante Nina Garet elle
installe des dizaines d'aspirateurs avec
des filtres un travail difficile dans
des conditions tropicales
[Musique]
les chauves-souris ça cache aussi dans
le creux des arbres c'est donc un bon
endroit pour échantillonner
pendant une bonne partie de la nuit les
filtres vont récolter les fragments
d'ADN qui flottent dans la forêt
tropicale
et quand on revient en laboratoire le
défi c'est de savoir à qui l'ADN
appartient
parce qu'en fait l'ADN c'est le langage
que toutes les formes de vie utilisent
un code à 4 lettres qui permet de
fabriquer autant un chêne qu'un
rhinocéros
l'idée c'est de cibler parmi ces
milliards de lettres des petites
séquences qui sont différentes pour
chaque espèce
on utilise ce qu'on appelle des amorces
c'est un peu comme si on avait un livre
avec un chapitre sur les mammifères et
qu'on visait une phrase en particulier
on cherche donc le premier et le dernier
mot de la phrase c'est ce que font les
amorces elles s'attache à des endroits
bien précis de l'ADN comme une clé dans
une serrure ensuite on peut photocopier
le Bouddha dn qui est entre les deux on
parle de séquence d'une centaine de
lettres à peine de tout petits fragments
qui survivent dans l'atmosphère en
regroupant ensemble les millions de
copies de chaque fragment on a assez
d'informations pour fouiller les bases
de données génétique et trouver à quelle
espèce chaque séquence de lettres
appartient et ici on parle de plusieurs
espèces de chauve-souris dont certaines
sont rares ou difficiles à observer
l'équipe a aussi trouvé de l'ADN de ce
jour-là d'oiseaux et de gecko bref c'est
un échantillon de la biodiversité et ça
pourrait suivre les traces de l'ADN dans
l'eau
en 20 ans on est passé d'une idée un peu
farfelue à un outil incontournable pour
identifier les espèces de poissons gérer
la pêche ou protéger un habitat
[Musique]
si l'ADN aérien a authenticé et ça va
tout changer on va pouvoir expédier nos
filtres à d'autres équipes ou les
laisser quelque part puis les récupérer
et connaître la biodiversité à cet
endroit
j'imagine déjà des avions qui survolent
les forêts avec des filtres géants mais
est-ce que ça va fonctionner on ne sait
pas et c'est ce qui est excitant parce
que c'est complètement différent
complètement différent en tout cas des
méthodes traditionnelles pour étudier la
biodiversité
pour les chauves-souris ça consiste
souvent à installer des filets et la
nuit à récupérer délicatement les
animaux
et les identifier du mieux qu'on peut
[Musique]
souris il y en a plus de 1000 espèces
ici on a le grand noctilion et donc
c'est une des rares chauves-souris qui
se nourrit de poissons en fait entre
autres ça prend donc des experts sur
place pour corriger les erreurs des
biologistes en herbe
[Rires]
pour les animaux plus difficiles à
attraper comme les jaguars on peut
utiliser des caméras et espérer qu'ils
passent devant ou même essayer de les
voir directement dans tous les cas il
faut énormément de travail pour récolter
parfois peu d'informations c'est tout
l'intérêt d'avoir de nouveaux outils la
beauté avec l'ADN environnementale c'est
que ça ressemble à une empreinte on peut
la trouver même si l'animal n'est plus
là quand vous prenez vos mesures il peut
passer s'en aller et laisser cette trace
derrière lui c'est une technologie
complémentaire aux autres cette nouvelle
outil mais on ne jette pas tous ces
tournevis parce qu'on vient de trouver
un marteau on se dit j'ai deux outils
qui peuvent faire des choses différentes
si l'outil fonctionne sa première
utilisation ce sera pour savoir si une
espèce en danger est présente ou non
ou encore si une espèce invasive comme
un insecte ravageur ou une plante qui
étouffe les autres a fait son apparition
dans une région donnée ce sont deux
façons de protéger la biodiversité et
c'est ce qui pousse les abeilles claires
à développer son nouvel outil son rêve
c'est de créer un réseau de station pour
récolter des données sur la biodiversité
un peu comme on le fait avec la météo
je pourrais rester au bureau et recevoir
des données d’adn de partout dans le
monde et les analyser en temps réel
c'est impossible en ce moment d'étudier
les changements dans les écosystèmes au
moment où il se produisent
et pour y arriver il reste encore
beaucoup de travail à faire pour
raffiner l'outil il faut un système à la
fois simple léger autonome et le moins
cher possible
[Musique]
notre expérience a suscité énormément
d'intérêt pour une scientifique c'est
vraiment satisfaisant quand quelqu'un me
dit c'est génial je vais essayer moi
aussi et je t'en redonne des nouvelles
et c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne nous
on a montré que c'est possible j'espère
que d'autres chercheurs vont raffiner la
méthode et me dire l'année prochaine on
a trouvé une meilleure façon de faire on
va vous montrer comment ce serait la
plus belle récompense pour nous
parce qu'en bout de ligne la véritable
course n'est pas entre les chercheurs
c'est celle pour préserver au maximum ce
qui reste de la biodiversité sur terre
[Musique]